i i have a request i feel like we're
friends now like we know each other well
enough where you were sending me last
night youtube videos of you and max
keiser talking and
i there's controversy here did max tell
you about bitcoin at ten dollars and you
just didn't want to buy it
max is full of [ __ ]
you know i mean max max lies about a lot
of things i mean i guess you know and
and sometimes that's part of what
happens you know in when you're pumping
bitcoin i mean look i
i i showed you these clips and anybody
could find these things i might put some
together and just like you know put out
a youtube video but i was doing max
kaiser's show you know back you know
when he when he was a lot more polite
and didn't you know call me all kinds of
names but i was doing his show in 2009
2010 2011 2012 you know and this is the
time frame where he claims that he told
me to buy bitcoin you know i teach said
i told him to buy it when it was under a
dollar
i didn't have any conversations with uh
max keiser about bitcoin at those levels
if you look at my interviews in 2011
2012 2013 right where i'm interviewed
for him you know 15 minutes i'm on his
show kaiser report we're talking about
inflation fiat money central banks hyper
inflation the return to a gold standard
buying gold all these conversations and
not once does max keiser mention bitcoin
or anything about bitcoin in fact you
can look at the entire shows where i'm
on and even before i come on he doesn't
mention bitcoin he doesn't talk about
bitcoin uh so i mean he may have been
mentioning it you know occasionally
during those years but he certainly
never mentioned it to me not publicly
not privately the first time i can
recall
max ever kind of like giving me some
crap about bitcoin was around 2014. now
yeah it was maybe 300 400 of bitcoin and
i was probably saying some negative
things about it and i think at that time
he started you know promoting it but not
just bitcoin he was telling people buy
all the cryptos i mean he liked bitcoin
the best but he said you know buy
ethereum you know buy you know whatever
coins he was like build a portfolio buy
them so yes he was recommending that
people buy him
when they were sever several hundred
dollars a coin right i mean he could
credit himself for that but he certainly
didn't tell me about it and he didn't
tell me about it when it was under 10
or under a dollar now
other people did i mean i'm you know i'm
not saying that i didn't know about it
back then i did people told me about
bitcoin i don't remember if it was as
low as below a dollar it's definitely
below ten dollars it could have been
below a dollar when i first heard about
it there were people telling me about it
but max keiser wasn't one of those
people so if somebody wants to come out
and say hey i told peter to buy bitcoin
below ten dollars he didn't do it there
are people who could say that max can't
you know he could lie and pretend but
but but he but we never had those
conversations if you bought bitcoin
under 10 dollars you'd be a trillionaire
you already know that hey guys thanks so
much for watching that clip of the best
business show make sure you like and
subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it